>> Greg: THAT'S VERY LOCAL TV.
WELCOME TO IS THIS EFFECTIVE?
THE SEGMENT WHERE WE TEST
MYSTERIOUS OINTMENTS THAT ARE
SENT TO US FROM VIEWERS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: BUT IT'S ALSO A CHANCE
FOR ME TO FORCE YOU TO WATCH
WEIRD STUFF I FOUND ON THE
INTERNET WITH ME.
SORRY GOVERNOR.
>> Gov. Noem: IT'S OKAY.
>> Greg: FIRST UP AN AD FROM
POLAND, ONE WITH A TWIST THAT
MAY INVOLVE A TRYST.
SHOW IT!
♪♪
♪
>> Greg: I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING, THAT'S ONE SEXY
SHOWROOM OVER AT RAYMOUR AND
FLANIGAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING.
BUT, WAIT.
THERE'S MORE.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> Greg: YEAH, THIS AD IS MEANT
TO SHAME PEOPLE WHO PARK IN
HANDICAPPED SPACES WHEN THEY'RE
NOT DISABLED.
IT'S CALLED DON'T OCCUPY THE
SPOT OF THOSE WHO NEED IT AND I
GUESS THE LESSON IS, HOW WOULD
YOU LIKE IT IF I PARKED IN YOUR
WIFE?
WHICH SEEMS KIND OF CRUDE, BUT I
GUESS THE GUY SHOULD THANK GOD
HE DIDN'T PARK IN THE FIRE LANE.
THEN THIS LADY REALLY WOULD HAVE
BEEN HOSED.
>> TAKES THAT SEXISTS WOULD SAY.
>> Greg: WHO WRITES THIS EMILY?
I AM APPALLED.
WAS THE AD EFFECTIVE.
>> Emily: THE VERSION I WATCHED
DIDN'T HAVE THE ENGLISH
TRANSLATION SO IT WAS UP TO ME
TO EXTRAPOLATE WHAT I WAS
SAYING.
SO IN MY HEAD HE WAS SLEEPING
WITH HIM BECAUSE HE HAD THE
DISABLED PARKING PLACARD.
>> Greg: THAT'S A BETTER ANGLE.
>> Emily: I DON'T FAULT HER.
KAT I WAS WATCHING THIS.
I FOUND THE GUY IN THE
WHEELCHAIR TO BE VERY SWARMY.
FORGET HE WAS IN A WHEELCHAIR I
FOUND HIS PERSONALITY TO BE A
PROBLEM
>> Kat: YEAH.
>> Greg: LOOK AT HIM.
COCKY CUCK HOLDER
>> Kat: NO, HE'S NOT THE CUCK
THE OTHER GUY IS.
.
>> Greg: CUCKEE.
THOSE ARE ACTUAL TERMS
>> Kat: I'M WELL AWARE.
I THINK THEY WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE IF THEY INSTEAD JUST
MADE IT A LAW.
YOU TAKE SOMEBODY'S PARKING SPOT
AND THEY GET TO BANG YOUR WIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD RUN FOR
OFFICE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Gov. Noem: I'M NOT GOING TO
BRING THAT BILL IN SOUTH DAKOTA
>> Kat: REALLY?
OH, MAN
>> Gov. Noem: STAY OUT OF THIS
CONVERSATION
>> Kat: I WAS HOPING TO GET A
SPOT ON YOUR STAFF.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THIS
ANALOGY WAS APPROPRIATE OR IS IT
KIND OF CRASS THE IDEA OF
COMPARING YOUR SPOUSE TO A
PARKING SPACE?
>> Gov. Noem: JAMIE?
>> Greg: HE'S DIVORCED BY THE
WAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK YOU JUST MICRO TRIGGERED
HIM?
>> Jamie: I WILL SAY I THINK THE
GUY DOING THE CHEATING, THE
DISABLED GUY, AND THE GUY COMING
HOME COULD AT LEAST USE THE SAME
EXCUSE FOR WA THEY DID.
THEY COULD JUST BE LIKE OH, I'M
JUST DELIVERING A PACKAGE.
I'LL JUST BE A MINUTE.
>> Gov. Noem: IS THAT A COUCH?
IS THAT A COUCH?
>> Greg: YEAH, WHY THE COUCH.
>> Gov. Noem: I WAS TRYING TO
FIGURE THAT OUT.
>> Greg: YEAH, WHY THE COUCH.
THEY MUST HAVE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION THAT IT HAD TO BE ON
A COUCH AND NOT IN A BEDROOM.
>> Gov. Noem: WHERE WAS THIS AD
AT?
>> Greg: IN POLAND.
YOU'RE POLISH
>> Kat: SURE AM.
>> Greg: YOU PROUD OF THIS WORK?
>> Kat: YEAH, I'M PROUD TO BE
POLISH.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
GOOD FOR YOU.